Vanessa Bryant reacts to Kobe's older
sister paying tribute to her late
husband and daughter Gianna with a new
tattoo Sharia Washington took to
Instagram on Wednesday to share her
fresh new ink honoring the late NBA star
and her niece
Vanessa reposted the snap to her own
account writing in the caption my
sister-in-law got this cool tattoo to
honor GG and Cobie 224 forever love you
Sharia sharia is a body art features a
snake in the shape of an infinity symbol
surrounding the numbers 2 and 24 Gianna
and Kobe's respective jersey numbers the
Black Mamba of course represents Kobe's
nickname on and off the basketball
courts tell me it goes by fast and if
you don't give it your all you're gonna
regret it you're absolutely going to
regret it before their sudden deaths
Kobe's 13 year old daughter was carrying
on the family basketball legacy with a
Mamba related nickname of her own Mamba
Sita
Vanessa's competitive uncompetitive it's
only natural that I kids in the same way
clearly Kobe and Gianna meant a lot to
so many as sure Ria's tattoo is one of
several memorializing the
father-daughter duo the rapper the game
paid tribute in the form of a face
tattoo while 2 Chainz got the number 2
on his right leg and the number 4 on his
left truly it's it's a gift Kobe's
longtime friend Shaquille O'Neal's son
Sharif referred to him as an uncle and
showed the tattoos he got on his
Instagram stories which included
Gianna's Jersey an image of Kobe holding
a basketball with his hands in the air
as well as both of Kobe's numbers 8 and
24 and Mamba mentality referring it to
Kobe's lasting legacy of inspiring
others to constantly try to be the best
version
of themselves it means everything it
means everything I think our
responsibility is to always inspire and
try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned and share those
with the next generations Lakers stars
LeBron James and Anthony Davis also got
tattoo tributes I mean we know that he's
watching over us and you know it's our
responsibility to just represent the
purple and gold not only for him before
all the grace
James and Davis didn't play alongside
Bryant on the Lakers
all three were teammates on the u.s.
men's national team winning gold at the
2012 Summer Olympics in London that's
the dream it's not the destination is
the journey